Russian President
Vladimir Putin says that his country
is going through a difficult time
as Ukrainian forces
claim success on the battlefield.
Putin's admission
came during his Russia day
address to the nation.
Ukraine's
military says that it has made gains
in the southeast,
recapturing three front line villages,
and they continue to make advances
on several fronts.
Joining me now
to discuss is Lieutenant
General Mark Hertling,
a CNN military analyst.
General, welcome to the program.
Good morning.
So I want to start there with that
new CNN reporting
that we are seeing at Vance's long
certain areas
of the border, Donetsk, for example,
zapping Russia.
What do you make of that?
These are still not the main attack,
in my view,
or how this is still
sort of the looking for places to attack
you know,
this is the very early stages of
this offensive.
And whenever you have an early stage,
what you're doing
is looking for an advantage
and attempting to move the enemy
forces around.
Ukraine is doing that.
They are probing in a very
a variety of direction.
The American public
all knows
now the military terms
of shaping operations
and probing and reconnaissance in force.
That's what they're continuing to do.
So you're seeing some tough fighting.
Ukraine has entered into the first two
of four complex obstacle belts,
and they are having great success
in liberating small villages.
But we're going to see what's
going to happen next.
And I'll introduce you to two new phrases
that we'll start using soon.
And that's main attack
and supporting attacks.
That's what Ukraine will eventually do
when they find out
the best places to employ their reserves.
General, as you say, early days
in this counteroffensive.
We're about one weekend,
but CNN is reporting that
at least according to an open source,
Intel Agence Analysis
that Ukraine has has lost 16
of its armored vehicles from the U.S.
It's about 15% of the 109 that the U.S.
had provided at this stage.
In the counter-offensive
early days, as you say.
What do you think about
that rate of loss there
When you're
whenever a force goes into an obstacle
belt, like you're
seeing Russia has built
over the last seven months,
you're going to lose vehicles
you're going to
they're going to get destroyed.
Truthfully, now,
when we're
talking about armored vehicles,
we don't know what type of each
kinds of armor vehicles
are these lethal tanks that they've lost,
are they Bradley fighting vehicles
or are they Strykers
or are they high marks?
We don't know.
Ukraine is doing a very good job in terms
of keeping operational security.
But truthfully,
I think everyone's getting excited
about the fact that Russia has shown
a couple of pictures
of what they claim are destroyed
Ukrainian vehicles.
But as heartless as this sounds.
That is to be expected
in the kind of operations
Ukraine is conducted
They're on the offensive
against a tough defensive belt.
So you're going to lose some vehicles
and unfortunately,
you're going to have casualties as well.
General, what do you make of Putin
saying that this is a
difficult time for Russia
Yeah, that's fascinating.
When I heard that report this morning,
he has increasingly admitted
some of the challenges
that Russia is experiencing now.
Part of that is to generate
additional support
from the Russian Russian people
as he attempts to mobilize more forces or
manufacture more vehicles,
more ammunition and do different things.
So when he says it's a difficult
time, he's basically signaling
I believe, to the Russian people
that we have to step up the operations
and that there will be
more pain and suffering,
whether it's in return
injured and killed
soldiers, Russian soldiers
or banks shutting down
or less goods on the market
or less opportunities for Russian people
to do that.
Kind of things
that they're used to doing.
So all of those things are signals
from a politician
to basically prepare for more losses
and more damages to his government.
Really fascinating statement now.
15 months into the war.
General, great to have you today.